[Musique]
combien de solution de rechange
existe-t-il à la castration des
porcelets
3 certains producteurs canadiens se
tournent vers l'immuno castration un
procédé par lequel on injecte aux
porcelets un produit qui stoppe la
production de stéroïdes par les
testicules cela entraîne l'élimination
des odeur désagréable lors de la cuisson
de la viande
une autre solution est le recours et on
est humain des employés renifle les
carcasses à l' usine et élimine celles
dont les odeurs pourrait s'avérer
déplaisant pour les consommateurs c'est
une solution plus facile à adopter quand
on élève des pieds train une race qui
présente un faible pourcentage d'animaux
ballots de rampeau de ce côté ci de
l'atlantique c'est la race du rock qui
est favorisée pour la qualité de sa
viande prose est juteuse elle a
toutefois l'inconvénient de dégager plus
d'odeur enfin certains pays ne castres
presque pas leurs ports en espagne par
exemple la viande de porc est
majoritairement transformée en saucisson
sec
il est donc plus facile de camoufler
ainsi les carcasses malodorantes que
dans de la viande fraîche